I feel bad about it but the shell on
turtles do they spawn with it I mean why
not use gamer call outs in real life I
thought process oh my God my grandma
just rotated in she has to go to sleep
I'm getting off at this c bar what the
is this dude this is just like another
this is like a a pack-a-punch Beaver oh
my God oh my God rare spawn oh my God
that's
him is vital for sucking the nectar but
with a t guys in are these Bears the
going be rare right whoa whoa whoa what
do I do
now left merge right side nope no no
no bro your coms
are zo your coms are absolutely
disastrous wow this thing don't give a
this thing just jumped off top
three on Terminal just running into
plane what the am I witnessing if I'm a
crocodile I'm unbelievably check